Traduttore: Peggy Berthier
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Allora, tornare a crederci.
Tornare a crederci per Carlsberg.
Esattamente dieci anni fa
mi hanno contattato
e i danesi, che sono
i proprietari di questa fondazione,
che è proprietaria di questa azienda,
mi hanno detto:
noi non ci crediamo più,
quindi vai e chiudi.
Non abbiamo altro modo
che uscire da questo territorio
perché in Italia sono anni
che perdiamo un sacco di quattrini.
Quindi, il tornare a crederci
era un tema delicatissimo
di un'azienda che era
con 1400 persone abbondanti,
1420 persone, che lavoravano,
non solo a Varese ovviamente
ma in tutta Italia,
ed era sostanzialmente un'azienda
con un piede alla fine.
Quindi, il tema principale che avevo
era far tornare a credere le persone
che lavoravano all'interno dell'azienda
anche perché,
come potete capire,
questo era comunque qualcosa
che l'avevano capito in tante persone.
Essendo a Varese, ed essendo io
un appassionato di pallacanestro,
ho detto: “Bisogna citare qualcuno
che evidentemente
ha a che fare con la città.”
Nel senso, Michael Jordan,
che è un grandissimo giocatore
di pallacanestro, dice:
"Posso accettare di fallire.
Chiunque fallisce in qualcosa".
Allora, detto da un giocatore
che ho visto personalmente a Chicago,
quando vivevo a Chicago, giocare,
questo concetto del fallire
è un elemento forte.
Perché il “fallire”
è sostanzialmente l'“apprendere”.
Io apprendo molto di più
dagli sbagli che faccio
che dalle cose giuste che faccio,
perché le cose giuste
che faccio sono scontate.
Gli errori mi aprono la mente, dicono:
- Ehi ragazzi, fermo! Ho fatto un errore,
devo per forza di cose rifare.
Ecco, una società
come quella che ho ereditato io,
era terrorizzata di fare qualsiasi azione,
anche perché evidentemente aveva
una storia di fallimenti costanti,
quindi le persone erano bloccate
nel loro processo
di sviluppo della società.
L’altro aspetto, che è sentimento comune,
è che ognuno di noi
poteva far la differenza
ma, in qualche modo,
tutti erano anche qui
in una situazione psicologica
tale per cui tutti si aspettavano
che c'era qualcun’altro
che dovesse fare il lavoro per loro.
C’era proprio la sensazione del:
“aspetto che qualcuno
mi dica cosa devo fare”.
Nessuno si poneva nel modo corretto.
Quindi, in realtà, quando io sono arrivato
- questa è un'azienda che aveva
esattamente 130 anni di storia,
quest'anno facciamo i 140.
E ho detto: signori, 130 anni di storia
sono un patrimonio straordinario.
Quindi, qui dentro
c'è un valore incredibile.
C'è un valore nella storia,
c’è un valore nei prodotti,
c’è il valore nelle persone
che lavorano qui dentro.
Quindi, probabilmente,
quello che non riusciamo a fare
è aprire gli occhi.
Dobbiamo guardare, dobbiamo vedere,
dobbiamo capire le cose
che possono funzionare.
E io avevo un vantaggio,
rispetto agli altri.
Non è che sono più bello,
più intelligente o più capace:
è che io sono arrivato
e non conoscevo questa storia.
Me la sono fatta raccontare,
sono andato proprio a capire
la storia di Angelo Poretti, dall'inizio.
Quindi, ho detto, partiamo dall’inizio,
partiamo da quando lui
ha fondato questa società
per capire qual era
il patrimonio che avevamo.
E l'altra cosa: io non capivo
nemmeno nulla di birra.
Grandissimo vantaggio.
Ero un bevitore di vino:
adesso sono convertito, ovviamente.
Ma, all'inizio, io capivo
anche molto poco della birra.
E questo è stato un altro vantaggio,
perché, in realtà,
guardavo, aprivo gli occhi,
in un modo che nessuno dei dipendenti
della nostra società riusciva ad avere.
Questo è un esempio
di cosa voglia dire “aprire gli occhi”.
Questa è una luce,
è un gioco, è una lampada.
Questi sono dei fusti di PET
che, giusto per farvi capire,
qui dentro noi mettiamo
20 litri di prodotto.
Quando io sono arrivato,
non ho inventato nulla.
C’era un manifesto gigantesco
all’ingresso delle scale
che facevo tutte le mattine.
Andavo su, vedevo questo manifesto grosso,
con un frigorifero e uno
di questi fusti pieni di birra.
Allora, ogni volta che ne parlavo,
le persone mi dicevano:
sai, i fusti d'acciaio, sono vecchi,
la qualità del prodotto non funziona,
è difficile, perdiamo i fusti,
ce li rubano, ogni fusto vale 60 euro…
Ed era una delle ragioni
per cui la società stava perdendo
una montagna di denaro.
Io vedo questa cosa sulle scale,
e alla decima volta che sono lì,
li ho guardati e ho detto:
Scusate, ma lì c’è
la foto della soluzione!
E questi mi guardano:
Ma come c’è la foto della soluzione?
Mi state dicendo
che i fusti non vanno, eccetera,
ma la foto è lì!
Ce l’abbiamo già!
Ma no, ne abbiamo lanciati 200,
sono rotti, sono tutti scoppiati a ridere.
Tutto il mondo lavora
con i fusti di acciaio.
Bene, tutto il mondo
lavora con i fusti di acciaio,
e noi lavoreremo
con questo banalissimo gioco.
E noi trasferiremo la birra qui dentro.
E la gente ha detto, ma questo
è completamente matto!
Non esisteva al mondo nessuno
che aveva fatto un'operazione del genere.
Va bene, lo facciamo noi!.
Oggi, a distanza di 10 anni,
siamo ormai al 95% di sostituzione
con un tasso di crescita incredibile.
Ma non solo:
questa tecnologia che, ripeto,
non è stata inventata
ma è stata sviluppata da noi,
questa tecnologia la stiamo esportando,
siamo diventati centro
di eccellenza mondiale,
la stiamo trasportando
in giro per tutto il Mondo.
Questo sarà il futuro
della distribuzione della birra.
Per tanti motivi: uno, per la qualità.
Il prodotto che noi beviamo
alla spina da qua
è dieci volte migliore
di qualsiasi altro prodotto dei fusti,
anche perché il fusto
mette dentro la CO2
quindi il prodotto, in qualche modo,
si ossida, in pochi giorni è ossidato.
Quindi, la qualità di un prodotto
in fusto è comunque perdente.
L'altro motivo
è per la sostenibilità ambientale.
Noi, in questi 300 grammi
trasportiamo dei prodotti
in giro per tutta Italia.
Nei fusti abbiamo dieci chili,
pensate solo l’impatto
di CO2 nell'atmosfera
nel portare dei fusti da qua a Trapani
e da Trapani riportarli indietro,
più tanti altri effetti collaterali.
Quindi questo, quando prima dicevo
“aprire gli occhi”, è che questo c'era.
Tanto per fare un esempio
delle cose che avevamo.
Non è stato inventato da nessuno:
non è che io abbia inventato niente.
Questo era qualcosa
che avevamo già presente.
Peccato che la gente rideva,
invece di sviluppare il progetto.
Paura.
Ecco, la gente ha paura.
Primo: la paura è un bel sentimento,
e io ne ho avuta tanta.
Perché quando si ha
la responsabilità di 1400 persone,
se sbagliavo, in realtà
andavano a casa 1400 persone.
Quindi, se non c'è paura..
Non dobbiamo aver paura di aver paura
(scusate il gioco di parole):
è giusto aver paura, è giusto,
è un sentimento che dobbiamo avere,
quando facciamo i cambiamenti,
perché evidentemente ci prepariamo anche
a dover gestire i problemi che nascono.
Ma la paura non deve essere bloccante.
Non è perché ho paura
di sbagliare, che non faccio.
E qui torniamo al punto di prima:
dobbiamo avere il coraggio
di poter fallire,
di fare un errore e tornare indietro.
Lo dico sempre alle persone
che sono intorno a me:
voi avete un grande vantaggio,
voi potete sbagliare quanto volete,
perché tanto chi si assume
la responsabilità dell'errore sono io.
Quindi, sbagliate quello che volete.
Ma non potete stare fermi,
non potete essere bloccati dalla paura!
Dopo di che, se l'errore che faccio
è troppo grande, sostituiscono me
e avete ancora la possibilità
di sbagliare un'altra volta.
Sostituiscono me.
Ed è giusto che sia cosí, peraltro.
Quindi la paura non deve essere
un sentimento che blocca
il processo di cambiamento.
Questo è il nostro cuore produttivo.
Qui c'è storia e c’è passato.
Qui si vede la storia
e sotto c'è il futuro.
Noi abbiamo delle tecnologie straordinarie
all'interno di questo stabilimento
perché è diventato uno dei punti
di riferimento a livello mondiale.
Tutte le tecnologie nuove
vengono prima testate
nel nostro stabilimento
e poi diventano patrimonio
a livello complessivo.
E questo è l'altro esempio.
Avevamo questa birra strepitosa,
ma fino al 2010
il birrificio Angelo Poretti
sostanzialmente lo conoscevate qua
perché siamo a Varese,
lo conoscevano le persone di Varese
ma io che vivo a Milano
e quindi non lontanissimo,
non sapevo nemmeno
dell'esistenza di questo marchio.
E la prima paura
- qui di paure ce n'erano tante.
I nostri competitor
hanno dei nomi esattamente uguali:
Poretti Moretti… Peroni Poretti…
E lo dico in inglese
perché la vicinanza è ancora maggiore.
Tutti si chiamavano allo stesso modo:
come si dice tecnicamente, “sfortuna”,
eravamo tre imprenditori
completamente diversi
tutti e tre con lo stesso nome.
Potevamo essere Giovanni,
Bianchi, Osvaldo:
no, tutti con lo stesso identico nome.
E quindi era giusto avere paura.
La paura qui era -
quando, ad un certo punto,
ho chiesto al mastro birraio..
tutti mi facevano bere la Splügen
-molti di voi la conosceranno-,
Ma perché mi fate bere la Splugen,
con tutte le birre buone che facciamo?
Lui mi rispose che questa
è la migliore che facciamo.
La migliore? dico io.
Ha un’etichetta blu da candeggina,
il prodotto declina,
sembra candeggina in una bottiglietta
per lavare i panni.
Com’è possibile che sia buona?
E mi fanno: no, è la migliore.
Allora vado dai mastri birrai
e dico: scusate, spiegatemi.
Eh, l’acqua è straordinaria,
viene dalla Fonte
degli Ammalati nella Valganna…
Fantastico, però l’acqua…
la dice Forst...
Poi ci sono i malti, mi dicevano.
Mah, ce l'han tutti i malti,
sono più o meno simili.
I lieviti, ma raccontare i lieviti
è un pochino difficile.
Poi ci sono i luppoli.
Ok, certo, nella birra c’è il luppolo.
Però nella notte, rifletto:
la birra ha il luppolo o i luppoli?
Per me era uno il luppolo,
non ho mai pensato
che ce ne fossero di tanti tipi.
La mattina dopo
ho telefonato al mastro birraio
e gli ho chiesto, scusa,
cosa vuol dire “i luppoli”?
- Eh beh, scusa Alberto,
ma lì ce ne sono 3!
Uno ceco, uno polacco
e poi c’è il cascade americano… -
- Ah, fantastico! E dico,
Ma poi ce ne sono altri?
- Eh si, in natura ce ne sono più di 300.
Oggi credo ce ne siano
circa 350 abbondanti...
- E se io domani voglio
una birra con 4 luppoli? -
Alberto, te la faccio con 4 luppoli -
E a 5? -
Ma scusa, Alberto, ce ne sono 350.
Che problema c’è?
Te ne faccio quanti ne vuoi!
Allora ho detto: perfetto.
La prima birra la chiamiamo
“Birrificio Angelo Poretti - 3 Luppoli".
La gente rideva!
I clienti dove sono
andato io personalmente…
Sono entrato in Esselunga,
ancora adesso me lo raccontano,
gli ho spiegato cosa stavamo facendo
e han detto: no , ma questo è matto!
e quando sono uscito
hanno riso per delle giornate.
No, no, è così!
Tutti, compresa l’azienda,
perché la gente non crede.
Dire che nella birra ci sono
i luppoli è la cosa più banale,
è come dire che nell’automobile
ci sono le ruote.
E certo, che ha le ruote
È un’automobile! Cosa deve avere?
Ha il volante! Eh, per forza!
Quindi, le cose più semplici
sono quelle che abbiamo davanti al naso.
Le cose più semplici sono quelle
che abbiamo davanti al naso.
Quindi, fallire, che è la paura di tutti…
E in azienda nessuno ormai
faceva più niente per non sbagliare più.
E quindi l’azienda era bloccata.
Tutti erano lì a indicare
appena uno spostava una penna
per poi dire: Eccolo qua,
che ha sbagliato!
Quindi, fallire, che poi è apprendere.
Che non è fallire, è apprendere.
Perché se uno non sbaglia,
non apprende. Io compreso.
Quindi, il fallimento è fondamentale
per cambiare la mentalità delle persone.
Anche di tutto il team.
E la cosa più importante
è giocare con una squadra.
E cambiare i posti.
Io non ho cambiato tutte le persone.
Ho cambiato tante persone
che riportavano a me.
Ma quelli che giocano oggi
sono le persone che io ho trovato.
Io non mi sono portato tanti manager
dall’esterno all’interno per rimpiazzare.
Li ho trovati lì.
Perché tra 1400 persone
se non ero capace di trovare
una squadra di gente vincente,
non ero capace di fare il mio mestiere.
Tornare. Così si torna a vincere.
E oggi ci credono.
E ovviamente, adesso è tutto più facile.
Però, in qualche modo,
abbiamo la possibilità di cambiare.
Abbiamo la possibilità di fallire.
Abbiamo la possibilità
di tornare a crederci.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)